merci beaucoupci euh on va passer auss
aux invités du soir c'est vrai que vous
nous l'avez vous nous l'avez réclamé he
cette séquence donc on on va la faire
c'est encore un sujet qui nous passionne
tous il y a quelques jours avec cette
fameuse question que tout le monde se
pose il y a-t-il une vie après la mort
Stéphan Alix va revenir il a consacré 15
ans de sa vie à cette question qui va
nous rejoindre vous allez voir il va
vous raconter des choses incroyables euh
voilà et vous allez vous allez
halluciner de ce qu'il va nous raconter
il sera accompagné de de Christel une
ancienne aide soignante qui est devenue
médium après avoir vécu une expérience
incroyable avec un défunt euh elle va
tout nous raconter je vous le dis
histoire de fou ce soir il est 20h52
petit recap ils sont avec nous juste
après merci à vous on vous embrasser
merci beaucoup merci à tous
regardez pour 30 % des Français il y
aurait bien une vie après notre décès et
certains déclare avoir vécu une
expérience de mort imminente que le
souvenir que j'ai en me réveillant du
coma c'est c'est de me voir au-dessus de
mon corps ouais de voir les machines mon
frère mon père de son côté Christelle
une ancienne aide soignante aujourd'hui
à la tête d'une société de pomes funèbre
et qui exerce une activité de médium
raconte quant à elle avoir vécu une
expérience incroyable avec un défunt
alors y a-t-il une vie après la mort
tandis que le journaliste et écrivain
Stéphan Alix qui a longuement étudié le
sujet sera sur notre plateau pour
évoquer la voyance et la mort imminente
Christelle partagera elle son expérience
extraordinaire dans
TPMP 20h53 je sais je sais que là il va
avoir énormément de monde dans la télé
puisque ce sujet vous passionne Stéphan
al merci d'être là Stéphane avant qu'on
parle à Christelle également être
soignante devenue médium qui va nous
raconter son histoire qui est incroyable
juste avant de commencer est-ce que vous
pouvez brièvement nous rappeler quelle
est votre théorie sur la question de
cette vie après la mort pour nos
téléspectateurs à 20h54 bah pour moi ma
théorie elle est basé sur 15 ans
d'enquête auprès de scientifiques de
médecins de neuroscientifiques qui
montrre que notre conscience une
dimension de notre conscience survit à
la mort de notre cerveau c'est pas une
croyance c'est pas une une une adhésion
spirituelle ou religieux c'est vraiment
un constat qui peut être fait
aujourd'hui par des médecins alors euh
on va revenir euh vous avez travaillé
avec des voignons des médiums vous avez
nous expliquer tout ça euh juste la
dernière fois vous m'aviez écrit vous
vous vous vous avez vécu une une
expérience de ouais ouais il y a 183
semaines maintenant que j'été que
j'étais j'étaé en réanimation et bien
évidemment ce qu'on appelle le voile
blanc euh c'était pas le rideau le pas
celui-là prod pas que tu produis non non
tu ça va mais mais effectivement en
réanimation quand le corps ne répond
plus on se laisse aller puis il y a une
forme de voile blanc quelque chose de TR
bien tu te sentais bien j'étais très
très heureuxoua j'étais bien je me suis
laissé aller il avait cette forme de
blancheur voilà espèce de couloir
ceappelle le couloir de la mortou voilà
où je faisais la queue et j'attendais ah
ou il y avait une queue même
là-bas tu es sûr que cétait pas chez
KFC non mais c'est vra B ben
incroyable Stéphan vousimz que vous nous
racontiez cette anecdote incroyable qui
vous concerne directement puisqu'elle
vient de de votre cousine
oui B ça c'est c'est étonnant parce que
dans le dans le disc cours de de de mon
enquête je j'ai été appelé par une de
mes cousines qui voulait me faire
visiter une maison dans lequelle mon
père avait vécu des années d'enfance
donc je su allait l' voir pas du tout
dans dans l'idée que j'allais entendre
un truc un peu extraordinaire et en
arrivant dans la maison qui est une
grande maison en cénémarne on est dans
le salon et ma cousine me dit bah tu
sais que maman est morte dans ce salon
elle a été hospitalisée à domicile et
elle est elle a fini ses joursl et avec
avec ma sœur on l'a veillé toute la
soirée donc la la maman était morte à
20h et vers 2h du matin ma cousine et sa
sœur enfin mes deux cousines donc sont
dans la cuisine en train de se préparer
une tisane et puis Olga ma cousine se se
se tourne et voit sa mère dans la
cuisine beaucoup plus jeune qu'elle ne
l'est dans son lit à quelques mètres de
distance avec un voile une sorte de
voile blanc une sorte de robe un peu
éterée et elle danse comme si elle était
extrêmement joyeuse de se retrouver dans
cet état-là ce qui est curieux c'est que
souvent quand les témoins voient ça il
doutent de même parce que tu c'est c'est
pas franchement le truc qu'on a
l'habitude de voir elle se tourne vers
sa sœur dit tu vois ce que je vois et sa
sœur lui dit bah oui je vois maman en
train de danser le Charl Stone et toutes
les deux ça a pas duré une seconde 2
secondes ça a duré plus d'une minute
cette vision les deux cousines devant
leur mère à quelques mètres de distance
qui est en train de de comme si elle
découvrait la joie d'à nouveau pouvoir
se bouger se se danser cétait quoi la
tisane elle l'avait pas encore bu la
tisane ce Bernard Jol très bonne
question l'abitude des Tian non c'est
fou non non mais y a une autre histoire
j'aimerais que vous racontez à nos
téléspectateurs c'est celle du papa qui
attend son fils qui rentre de boîes de
nuit c'est quoi cette histoire ouais ça
c'est une histoire dans le même registre
cette histoire de la de la maman de ma
cousine ça s'appelle un vscd vécu
subjectif de contact avec un défunt faut
que tu saches que plus de 50 % des gens
en deuil vivent ce type d'expérience et
l'histoire de ce papa c'est un un papa
qui a donné la permission de minuit à
son gamin qui est parti en boîte de nuit
il attend dans le salon comme des
millions de papas sans doute et puis un
peu aprèsminuit le fils rentre il entre
dans l'entrée il regarde son père sans
sans dire un mot son père lui dit bah
bonne nuit le fils monte dans sa chambre
et puis une demi-heure après coup de
coup de sonnette à l'entrée le papa va
ouvrir la porte et c'est les gendarmes
qui viennent lui annoncer que son fils
est mort 3h plusutôt
et cette expérience a été bah tu peux
l'imaginer bouleversante pour le papa
parce que c'est à la fois impossible et
pourtant il y a toutes les
caractéristiques d'une expérience
absolument réelle quand on le vit moi
j'ai vu ça chez des centaines de témoins
qui sont comme nous tous on vivrait ça
quand on en entend parler on se dit oui
c'est n'importe quoi ils ont dû
confondre ils ont dû délirer mais quand
on le vis soi-même on est à la fois
stupéfait par l'intensité de la réalité
d'une telle expérience et en même temps
on se dit mais c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible et
pourtant parfois c'est aussi visuel
aussi aussi flagrant que ça et je suis
sûr que parmi les les gens qui nous
écoutent il y en a des des centaines de
milliers qui ont vécu ce type
d'expérience après le décès d'un proche
c'est fou alors il il y a eu plein de de
plein d'histoires que vous allez nous
raconter vous allez voir euh c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est complètement fou
parce que déjà cette histoire il y a il
y a une autre lors du décès de votre
père vous avez euh vous avez eu une
expérience qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah
moi je suis journaliste donc j'essaie de
faire euh enfin j'essaie pas je fais des
enquêtes j'essaie de croiser des
informations et euh j'ai entendu parler
de la médiomnité au début de mon
activité de d'enquête sur le sujet de la
vie après la mort j'ai rencontré
Christel à cette occasion et euh
Christelle dans un instant vous allez
voir c'est et j'entends souvent des
histoires de médiums ou des histoires de
de patients qui sont allés voir des
médiums qui disent c'est incroyable il a
reconnu tel objet il a reconnu telle
chose il m'a donné tel détail sur mon
sur mon fils sur mon parent et donc
quand mon père est mort j'ai eu cette
idée un peu saugrenue de faire une sorte
de deal avec lui de lui dire papa si tu
es quelque part si tu m'entends je vais
cacher des objets dans ton cercueil je
vais le dire à personne c'est il y a pas
un être vivant qui va savoir de quoi de
quoi il s'agit ni même que j'ai fait
cette expérience là et à peu près un an
après la mort de de mon père et son
enterrement je suis allé voir six
médiums dont Christel sans lui dire
absolument ce que je voulais faire faire
en leur disant juste que je voulais
faire un livre d'entretien et que je
voulais qu'on fasse une séance de minité
pour voir ce qui se passait pour voir si
mon père allait se manifester et ça a
été juste incroyable parce que non
seulement mon père s'est manifesté
auprès des six médiums mais il a pu
aussi donner certains des objets à
plusieurs d'entre eux incroyable c'est
fou et c'est tu vois c'est de la selle a
trouvé tous les objets ah Christelle
elle a çaété une drôle d'hoire elle a vu
mon père elle l' elle a communiqué avec
lui elle a vu un des objets et elle a eu
peur tu veux raconter PE
euh en fait c'est toujours
impressionnant de se faire tester parce
que je savais très bien que Stéphan Alix
venant me voir voilà il y avait il y
avait sûrement quelque chose qui était
derrière et
eu dès que j'étais en contact avec son
papa il il a directement été
montré là où étaient cachés les objets
en fait hein était sous son corps voilà
et il a été directement alors justement
on va parler de vous parce que après on
aura d'autres anecdotes avec avec
Stéphane mais euh est-ce que vous pouvez
nous racontez déjà cette expérience
cette fameuse expérience de l'homme qui
vous donnait des instructions pendant
que vous faisiez sa toilette mortuaire
vous étiez aide soignante hein voilà
j'ai été aide soignante pendant plus de
10 ans donc j'étais essentiellement être
soignante de nuit ce qui veut dire que
j'étais vraiment au contact des patients
dans cette phase de fin de vie et cetera
et cette nuit-là j'ai eu un un patient
qui est décédé et et j'ai dû faire la
toilette mortuaire alors bien entendu
travaillant de nuit je je savais pas
qu'il allait décéder cette nuit-là donc
j'avais pas d'information et cetera et
au moment de de de faire ce soin ce que
j'appelle ça un soin même si il est
décédé c'est un soin et il me donnait
les instructions alors fais comme ça
n'oublie pas mon B par quel moyen par
quel comment vous alors ça peut être
étrange de le dire comme ça mais
j'entends j'entends une voix qui arrive
au niveau c'est très ciblé où est-ce que
ça arrive cette cette voix puisque ça
arrive derrière l'oreille droite
et c'est quelque chose qui est très pas
intrusif mais voilà c'est très soudain
et fais C fait ça voilà ce sont des
informations relativement précises vous
c'était sa voix parce que vous le
connaissiez avant je ne sais pas je peux
pas dire que c'était sa voix c'était une
voix masculine vous vous êtes donc
médium euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
vous avez eu un accident de voiture
surtout à un moment la voix lui dit
oublie pas ma casquette oui ou et du
coup Christelle se dit mais quelle
casquette et en cherchant au fond du sac
elle découvre qu'il y a une casquette
donc l'info elle l'avait pas bien sûr
alors que j'avais pas fouillé le sac
auparavant depuis votre accident de
voiture à 8 ans vous êtes devenu médium
alors je suis devenu médium c'est un
grand mot j'ai j'ai j'ai pris conscience
de ces ses perceptions en fait s'est
passé en fait pendant cet accident de
voiture je me suis retrouvée donc
éjectée à l'époque on avait pas la
ceinture de sécurité obligatoire donc je
me suis retrouvé éjecté sur le tableau
de bord de la voiture qui qui qui était
en train de se prendre une tête de pont
et au moment où j'ai été
éjecté j'ai je me suis retrouvé trouvver
dans une lumière en fait j'ai pas vu de
tunnel j'ai pas vu de de choses comme on
peut entendre et et je me suis retrouvé
dans un espace en fait que je pourrais
même pas identifier et petit à petit il
y a des choses qui se sont dessinées à
moi
comme des petites fleurs un arbre assez
assez gigantesque et est apparu mon
grand-père maternel d'accord que je n'ai
jamais connu puisqu'il est décédé quand
j'avais l'âge de 9 mois mais dans cette
expérience je savais que c'était lui en
fait sans même parler avec lui je savais
que c'était lui avec des pointes de
détail physiquees que je ne connaissais
pas parce que des photos j'en avais très
peu vu à 8 ans puis à 8 ans j'étais pas
à regarder comme ça les photos et c'est
à la suite donc je je me suis réveillée
dans l'habitacle de la voiture les
pompiers étaient là et cetera et à la
suite de cette expérience j'ai j'ai eu
ces perceptions médiumniques qui qui se
sont mis en place petit à petit alors
vous dites que vous échangez avec les
personnes décédées avec les morts euh
les défuns vous parlent en fait c'est ça
alors j'aime pas dire les défuns me
parlent parce que je suis dans le milieu
funéraire et quelqu'un qui est mort est
mort voilà scientifiquement parlant
quelqu'un de physiquement mort et il y a
pas de possibilité de communiquer c'est
une communication subtile en fait donc
je parle avec la survivance de du corps
donc l'âme donc vous parlez non mais
quand vous dites vous parlez avec avec
les avec les avec les morts qu'est-ce
qu' ils vous disent quoi en fait alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils me disent c'est et
parfois j'ai des défunts qui sont dans
ce besoin de communiquer à leurs proches
parce qu'ils sont dans la culpabilité
parce qu'ils sont dans la colère de de
leur décès parce qu'ils ont pas
suffisamment transmis de choses de leur
vivant et ce alors il y il y a un défunt
qui qui qui vous a parlé de ses enfants
par exemple oui tout à fait mais c'est
assez souvent il vous a dit quoi bah
souvent ce sont des défunts qui veulent
transmettre à leurs proches qu'ils sont
quelque part donc souvent c'est pour
rassurer leurs enfants leur dire ben par
qu' y a un défunt qui vous a dit qu'il
avait trompé sa femme toute sa vie ça
arrive malheureusement ça arrive ça fait
partie de la culpabilité mais Raymon
n'est pas
[Rires]
mort c'est pour la VAN c'est pour la VAN
merci c'était pour la VAN comment donc
il vous parle à l'arrière de l'oreille
en fait c'est ça vous arrive même que le
défunt vous parle dans une autre langue
ou avec un accent oui ça arrive quand on
est sur un dé qui est d'origine
étrangère et cetera ça fait partie aussi
des signes de
reconnaissance que de qu'il me parle
dans sa
langue orig juste est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter l'histoire de l'homme avec
le doigt amputé parce que c'est une
histoire de fou si vous nous rejonez à
21h5 c'est un truc de fou cette histoire
c'était lorsque
j'intervenais dans une conférence donc
on fait des contacts en public en fait
he quand on est dans des conférences qui
sont organisées par des associations
d'aide au deuil
et je suis là pour transmettre les
messages des défunts mais sans photos
sans rien donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
que le défunt soit très précis dans sa
description physique pour que la
personne qui est dans le public puisse
le reconnaître et là notamment j'ai eu
un défunt qui est arrivé avec un
physique les yeux bleus les cheveux
grisonnants et il me montre qu'il était
amputé d'un doigt ouais voilà donc dans
le public une personne a levé la main
effectivement la description qui était
donnée correspondait à son papa qui
était décédé
euh c'est c'est ça qui est frappant avec
la médiumnité c'est qu'on peut on peut
vérifier ces ces ces informations là
est-ce qu'un médium est capable de
donner des choses très très précises qui
pourrai pas s'appliquer à n'importe qui
ou est-ce qu'on est dans des choses
extrêmement vagues et dans les tests que
j'ai fait avec Christel ou avec d'autres
médiums c'est ça que j'ai pu mettre en
évidence parfois le le le le le médium
capte un un un détail extrêmement précis
de la vie du défun ou des circonstances
de sa mort qui peut pas s'appliquer à
n'importe quel autre défunt et ça
indique de façon assez certaine que le
médium parle vraiment avec quelqu'un à
ce moment-là alors vous euh euh c'est
quoi cette cette histoire de parce qu'il
y a quelqu'un qui nous dit l'expérience
dont parle l'invité ça s'appelle un
retard de perception tu vois quelque
chose avant que le cerveau ne l'analyse
bref c'est quelque chose de connu ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure ce que j'ai
dit c'està-dire tout à l'heure que vous
avez parlé de fils de votre de votre
fils de vre de votre papa ou je sais pas
quoi ah oui non de votre de son fils
avec le avec la boîte la discothèque ah
oui
[Musique]
euh non c'est pas ça c'est pas ça je
peux pas répondre c'est un peu trop
technique mais je pense qu'il y a dans
notre société on essaie assez rapidement
de se débarrasser de tous ces phénomènes
parce qu'il dérangeent quand même on
invente des théories on invente des des
explications pour s'en sortir un petit
peu comme avec les expériences de mort
imminente ù des chercheurs continuent à
dire non non ça se passe forcément dans
le cerveau en oubliant que par exemple
quand une personne vit une expérience de
mort imminente elle est capable de
sortir de son corps et d'aller voir ce
qui se passe dans une pièce d' côté en
parlant de mort imminente est-ce que
c'est quoi cette histoire de de ce
garçon qui a vu sa sœur pendant son coma
bah ça c'est une des expériences
justement les plus troublantes c'est il
y a il y a c'est c'est une expérience où
où pendant l'expérience de mort
imminante souvent les témoins racontent
avoir vu des personnes décédées alors on
peut
objecter de façon sceptique que bah oui
s'il a vu sa grand-mère décéde il sait
qu'elle est morte et il peut inventer
l'avoir vu ça peut être une sorte de
rêve mais il y a des expériences et il y
en a une autre qui est encore plus
impressionnante comme ça où un un une
personne dans le coma pendant 3 semaines
a vu à un moment de son coma le voisin
de chez ses parents qui est venu le voir
dans le coma pendant une expérience de
Mor imminente pour lui dire bah je suis
mort c'est pas ton moment de t'en aller
tu vas revenir la personne est sortie du
coma et quand il est sorti du coma il a
raconté cette expérience et ces parents
lui ont dit mais dis donc le voisin il
est mort il est mort pendant que tu
étais dans le coma et ça il avait aucune
information évidemment il était dans le
coma pendant que la personne était morte
donc ce type d'expérience elles peuvent
pas s'expliquer par une sorte de de
reconstruction psychologique et moi
justement je me suis attaché à essayer
de d'identifier toutes les causes
possibles à ces expériencesl tu t'en
doutes bien c'est le travail de
journaliste que j' essayaé de faire donc
est-ce que ça peut être C est-ce que ça
peut être ça est-ce que ces expériences
on peut les expliquer d'une manière ou
d'une autre et ce qui ressort de cette
enquête de 15 ans d'enquête et de
travail sérieux journalistique là-dessus
c'est que non il y a des millions
d'expérien qu'on ne peut pas réduire à
des phénomènes connus qui indiquent
qu'il y a quelque chose de nous qui
survit à la mort alors euh il y a il y a
une histoire aussi folle parce que je
sais que vous adorez quand on vous
raconte ce genre d'affa et qui sont il y
a plein de gens qui disent c'est vrai
j'ai vécu la même chose et cetera il y a
une anecdote complètement folle d'une
femme opérée d'un d'un anévrisme euh oui
ça c'est un cas assez connu la la femme
s'appelle Pamela elle a été opérée d'un
anivrisme qui était alors on va rappeler
ce ce qui un anivrisme voilà pour c'est
une une rupture de l'alimentation
sanguine du cerveau hein c'est ça donc Z
et là il fallait intervenir au milieu de
son cerveau parce que l'anivrisme était
vraiment au milieu du cerveau donc ça
nécessitait de la mettre en en
hypothermie de baisser la température de
son corps à 15°gr de sortir tout son
sang du corps pour pouvoir arriver sur
la névrce au milieu du cerveau et
pendant l'opération euh avant même qu'on
lui ouvre le crâne cette femme est
sortie de son corps et a vécu une
expérience de Mor imminente elle est
elle a observé déjà le bloc opératoire
puis après elle est partie dans la
lumière elle a rencontré des êtres
décédés et elle est revenue pend pendant
pendant une opération on peut partir on
peut sentir voilà qu'on bah souvent les
les témoins rapportent avoir observé la
scène du dessus le bloc opératoire
l'accident de voiture c'est ce qu'on
appelle le corps astral c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler le corps astral c'est un
des un des un des des explications qu'on
donne et ensuite là il y a une
expérience beaucoup plus extatique où
ils partent dans la lumière ils sont en
dehors de notre dimension présente et
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est quels sont
les éléments qu'ils ont perçu pendant
cette phase vous é elle a vu quoi elle
et elle elle décrit plein de détails qui
se sont passés pendant le bloc
opératoire à un moment une infirmière
devait lui faire une piqûure sur la
jambe gauche elle a pas réussi à trouver
la veine elle l' fait sur la jambe
droite Pamel là elle voit ça au plafond
donc c'est pas un détail qui peut être
réinventé après c'est quelque chose qui
s'est passé mais pour moi le chose elle
a entendu aussi une chanson ça c'est au
retour mais avant de partir avant de
partir elle a observé le chirurgien
commençait à lui ouvrir la boîte
crânienne avec un un instrument
particulier là je mets au défi qui qu
conque si je demande de dessiner avec
quel instrument on lui a ouvert le crâne
de dessiner le bon instrument parce
qu'on va dessiner une C on va dessiner
quelque chose qui ressemble à une s
l'instrument qui a ét utilisé pour
ouvrir sa boîte crânienne ressemble à
une brosse à dent c'est un truc un peu
biscornu vraiment avec une une sorte de
de petite dispositif qui permet d'ouvrir
le crâne elle l'a dessiné précisément
donc ça c'est pas quelque chose qu'elle
aurait pu imaginer qu'elle aurait pu
voir avant elle est arrivé au bloc elle
était déjà endormie c'est pas quelque
chose qu'elle aurait pu déduire en
voyant ça dans une série télévisée elle
avait aucune information là-dessus elle
décrit l'objet précisément et puis elle
part et quand elle revi bien parce
qu'elle a rencontré des proches décédés
qui lui ont dit c'est pas ton moment ça
c'est ça c'est aussi extrêmement
fréquent c'est quoi elle a vu des gens
qui étaient partis qui ont dit non tu tu
vas pas mourir et souvent c'est ça dans
l'expérience de Mor éminante c'est pas
le moment faut pas que tu franchisses il
y a comme un point où on sait que si on
franchit ce point cette lumière cette
barrière on va pas revenir et quand on
vit l'expérience on a qu'une envie c'est
de passer de l'autre côté et il y a
souvent quelqu'un ou une voix qui nous
dit c'est pas le moment o tu reviens PEL
est revenu elle a elle a réintégrer son
corps mais avant de réintégrer son corps
elle entend hôtel California dans le BO
opératoire la chanson des Ig ouais euh
qui est un peu vieux mais moi j'ai dansé
dessus quand j'étais gaminord et euh et
chose curieuse c'est la chanson que
passe le chirurgien à chaque fois qu' en
fin d'opération quand il recoule les
patients et qu'il les term sauf que
Pamela à ce moment-là elle est
absolument pas en capacité d'entendre
quoi que ce soit elle a des oreillettes
dans les oreilles qui diffusent un bruit
extrêmement fort pour mesurer son
activité cérébrale donc elle peut pas
entendre elle a pas l'appareillage ni
les oreilles ni rien du tout pour
entendre quoi que ce soit et c'est un
dernier détail qu'elle a capté juste
parce qu'il y y a plein de gens qui
réagissent làus quand on est en en mort
vous dites quoi imminente vous dites on
voit on voit des des gens qui sont
partis donc des gens décédés et ils vous
disent c'est fou cette histoire qui vous
dit NON NON toi tu tu faut pas que tu
restes là ah c'est systématique c'est
systématique c'est comme si on était
accueilli mais ça ça ça veut dire aussi
quelque chose d'important ça veut dire
que je pense qu'au moment où on meurt on
est accueilli on est accueilli par des
gens qui cette fois nous disent pas
retourne sur terre c'est pas ton moment
mais qui nous accueille dans cet espace
là ça je pense que Christelle peut nous
en parler aussi comment c'est à la
réception non non mais Christelle c'est
vrai ça ouais c'est vrai ça j'ai pu
l'observer quand j'ai accompagné les
personnes en fin de vie au moment de du
mourir en fait eu alors je vais parler
selon mes expériences vécues
hein ressentir et voir même plein de
monde dans la chambre mais qui était
invisible et qui étit là pour accueillir
justement cette cette personne qui était
en train d'amorcer son passage oui et
c'est ça qui m'a je crois toujours
rassuré euh dans dans dans cette mort
qui peut parfois paraître injuste et de
se dire bah voilà ça s'arrête mais il y
a quelque chose et et on prend le relais
voilà ça veut dire que je j'avais le
relais qui était pris derrière moi
j'avais fait mon travail de soignant et
ah vous avez senti le relais bah merci
merci Stéphan Alix merci Christel du
bois rituel pour apaiser un cœur en
deuil aussi merci à tous tout de suite
documentaire
sur